Oh gross welcome back to my nightmare
PewDiePie night for me oh god I hate
pings that's my nightmare I know it
what are you doing here Susu go on
everyone I what are you doing here get
the heck out here brah I don't trust you
alright Sano
it's about out of pity I waited for your
like I am tired today what are you doing
I said I'm just gonna pick up your shoe
boxes and waste my oil
guess why not and then we're gonna go
here start with a loading for you why
not oh nevermind can't go apparently
are you stupid idiot you probably forgot
the key or something yeah I probably did
that all right this way bidding while
this rice creep oh yeah oh yeah I
remember now I remember now
there's a lot of stuff for going off and
we were like going through Carter radars
I think I like corridors it's this one
time I actually hate court right what am
I talking about are doing I mean it
could be super fat ugly disgusting I
hate you look at you yeah you disgust me
and I don't just yeah thank you
give me my Latin and I madman
where's the key brah why am I wasting my
lion Brock where's the gate where's
brake mr. chair huh I'm ready I'm not
gonna tell you what it can
are you free control that would Sears oh
how do I progressed there hey sweetpea
do it might be housed somewhere what the
heck is going on oh this is why the bro
came from and you're out of oil good for
you baby
good for you all right so dark now I can
complete it where am I oh hey there's
something under what's going on here why
is it alight here makes no it's not oh
wait I have a lot on this way all right
I always forget to go off night oh no
ways I don't trust ya stupid I always
forget I don't trust you either
right god this gonna be a lot of
untrusting yeah yes now thank you
all right No
hello penny so you're back here I told
you how that works no okay
you shoulda listened how much to say you
should election look at I got I farted
Amin yes for you Josh Frank ah I'm gonna
leave no I don't leave me penny I love
you oh okay it's through that again
hopefully the pack ever again it's the
phone oh where are you
vana it's about okay they got I'll SPD
okay do it again pull that lever or
maybe wait did it even the door open God
Wow darling back the lid back throw it
back throw it back throw it back throw
it back the only bag I got this no
problem
okay I think we're good hey cricket
sound bra ah
all right Steve Allah help me I am I
don't know I haven't fully News down
through what's going on
is it safe Savannah I can't see God
close it is it good huh this is doing
that back man
okay we're good no it's like y'all
thank you boom hello it takes to burn up
Oh Bert wait I got this I got this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes I thought it was a proofer it makes
no sense cuz he comes out of nowhere how
leavin now a Lurie where the [ __ ] am i
hey do you fat stupid I'm just at you
hello panty are you dying
you need my help against him you need my
help after all and everything I know you
allowed me don't you pity don't tell me
you let me share mode ok
I keep telling you my chair mode but you
never listen where's the phone at first
of all I think that's a Joel Joel lever
ah just you can I go here now
alright can't go I know I really do that
twice oh whatever
ok I hope Stefano's here on the other
side on the other side there yes holy
crap
oh there you go say down Savona whatever
I'm breakdancing the ladies love it you
know you know what they say about men
who dance they get all the you know
things ok hey Jim barrels
[Applause]
stupid barrels no one likes you you're
not a totally to move Stewart barrels
Hank I'm gonna do this barrels you can't
say that okay
this looks pretty [ __ ] bad pity they
get really nice and easy okay fine I'll
good I can do anything I know I'd be
barrel doing something no those go I
don't want to do this oh I came three I
got a pickup Stefano I got a turnaround
and I gotta run
might do it use that Nana and man madam
make it one to know was a roofer it was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh unless I should have
used cherimoya
yeah Tony Paddick yeah I'm out activate
chasers crying it's that simple it's a
lot of time I tell ya alright okay again
now let's get my potato farting sighs I
can't fit it let's pretend that didn't
happen
you know ever reputation okay
[ __ ] this [ __ ] god and it's farting
potatoes okay again and it's gonna
explore this table more Stefano's no no
it's in pot mr. Phan how are you doing
talking to them I don't know I'm like
it's my buddy's like this one is
Rodriguez this is I'm stuck okay okay
I'm gonna say that this is Enrico si si
I am Enric oh I have the same boy system
okay whatever
oh no what is this I don't approve this
many barrels there's got to be secrets
behind these barrels
the battles rap-rap get stupid yeah yeah
come here wait oh it's fine I need fun
I'm not going anywhere with wait okay
Savannah come on hey verdict get me out
of this battle
okay fine what keep messing other voices
all right whatever
what hey I'm stuck
kamu okay there we go
this lot is a lot of fun a nuts gonna
like I'm gonna Savannah Savannah Oh Mike
we don't have to find any more bras oh
okay okay this looks bad I mean if
there's some real life I would have not
probably gone there I would have
probably just sit right here and cried
and probably peed a little bit and be
like I don't want to go up to stage Wow
or something I don't know
okay we'll do this as it goes I see
YouTube I'm doing this for you bro okay
think how anyone there ah God is a
corridor [ __ ] hate corridors I'm not
gonna lie this kid definitely is gonna
be something bad behind this door oh
[ __ ]
I just know it I just not okay
hello I'm just tiny melon ball rolling
around me in the corridor of amnesia
something here nothing there
alright I'm just gonna keep on rolling
and rolling something here nope
alright
No okay we're getting no no okay can we
get any new it Oh God does yeah get out
okay nice job M and V G brofist to you
as really fun to play I don't know I
hope you guys enjoyed this as well if
you want to you can like even that is
your favorite you really helped me out a
lot credits song is I don't know I
should stop before and give me like
copyrights things but anyway that's it
[Music]
what do you want from me
what is this ha ha panning it up BTW i
am stefano